welcome to this blitz game playing
gorgeous from russia russian flag at
least so let's get going okay i think
it's a king's indian no it's the goon
felt I thought I play the Kings Indian
before again sir but probably wrong
wrong assumption ok he knows his stuff
but should be six as the main line of
this nowadays oh really I thought I
thought d take c4s played but i'm not a
huge expert here DTS
okay i'm going to cheek them fatigue
soon added super-sharp 95 Bishop g4 f3e
five things like that as soon as
possible here I think mmm now you caught
me that it's something that I don't wait
on
it's fairly inconvenient this 95 per
shoot you for this says something else I
can play I really have no idea maybe
maybe I can play this one through a
covering see for this way that's not the
right move probably but not g5 picture
before f-35 looks like something I don't
want to try to solve over the board yeah
I wasn't aware that c5 is a movie no I
came I'm working a bit on the green felt
for what but I have not come to there's
this line yet okay some seedy nights III
added definitely okay fam and night xe5
mmm
Jeff he's got a very nice development
them night c5 queen a three that should
be ok I hope you can check on c3 and T
on c4 it's definitely ok for black I
amongst other selves probably something
else night c5 Queen a3 I think should be
ok maybe even Queen B 5 ok place that
Queen I thought couldn't be five maybe
even though is this somehow ridiculous
it's not ridiculous in itself ok this is
hanging but I already let me get out of
this him I want to have rook team won
the right moment you can take on c3
takes e4 but then i can take be seven
and i have root be one of the temple as
sorry rook do you want as a temple move
okay if i go look d 1 now queen bee six
probably so I should probably take him
okay that's interesting
I can't guess I guess Ruby one being
active takes rook takes bishop c3 rook
see one let's know for position for just
plain passer moves em so I have an
active rook if you click c3 I have Roxy
one Bishop back Bishop c4 Knight a5
maybe i can i can i can play a rogue c7
as an intermediate move i thought at
least Roxy 7
and yeah I think okay Oh Bishop is
Bishop b2 no no but then i have put
should be six probably not okay it's not
not a huge deal we should be too i can
even play a bishop be one or something
Oh whoopsie too yeah I'm pretty okay
with that position here considering that
he caught me off guard question is is it
better for me and if he takes there Luke
shakes the night thats a bit and a bit
of an unlucky spot my room i Luke is
more active huh maybe I should maybe yes
to go Bishop b2 ok ok I can know I can
take C 896 yeah let's let sets the point
so we cannot play Bishop down if you
move the bishop away here like Bishop g4
I have bishop oops f7 at least for Luke
take 36 and Bishop chicks yeah that's
not a move your love to play so going to
take a guess or not ok let's taken
so I can take on f7 intermediate move
what take them if I play this
intermediate movie has night hmm ok I
think I rather take this ok this is this
is a problem but I can go a 45 maybe
that makes sense anyway taking away the
d5 square idea is to play a five to cut
off his bishop of course it takes a bit
of time ok now i was thinking night g56
is a his eyes his a porn is running
though maybe Knight d4 armor and then
route 28
ah the time come on now they pawn and
this is probably too risky what I'm
doing probably came that's not ideal do
i doing I should have done something
about this pawn and a bit earlier I know
you can take you three check check ah
what a shame that I totally miss polite
resigns from a totally good position
here that was really okay for what
losing is bad it's really bad from this
position ok computer just wants to go
away three edits that's a conservative
move of course and maybe I should have
done that this was a bit more ambitious
but my main issue was I was just taking
far too long and go it is very risky
with the a pawn bishop h6 is probably a
good idea here here and now I can just
take it seven why don't I do that and
win check why will I playing them I
don't know and then he just loses let's
move just made
I was some off completely forgetting
that I can check with the rook yeah my
problem was I was thinking that he might
play a root da door something in this
position which is kind of ridiculous
anyway but okay yeah it's his bloody
first games in a session I've given up
on the warm-up games because i suck
there anyway so let's just get going and
this is this is bad yeah why twin see
I'm just just very simply and now now
he's winning Luke c5 is still ok
actually 497 but okay I was I wasn't
really playing well here in this in this
game anyway okay thanks for watching